[Applause]
punching with your lance like that
no not not not good you're not going to
get anything by throwing a punch except
for a broken wrist or a broken hand hi
i'm shane adams the owner of the knights
of valor full contact jousting company
i've been jousting for well over 25
years since i have 20 international
josting championships under my belt
today we're going to be looking at
horseback fights in movies and judging
how real they are
they hit but it was just a
a glancing blow there is no penalty for
missing your opponent but you're going
to be uh you know behind in points if
you hit the target whether it be a
a smooth plate or whether it be a targ
shield you get a certain amount of
points and ultimately if you unhorse
your opponent in the full contact style
that's the maximum amount of points
there there's you know probably well
over 19 20 25 different styles of
jousting
yeah see that ridge around that shield
bad news
you don't want a lip around the shield
you don't want any spot where that lance
is going to connect and lock in to the
lip you want to be able to deflect the
lance away from your body so
completely wrong shield
the jousting that was there
uh
it was decent for a theatrical style
jost if there were true knights
they wouldn't be holding their shields
like that they're leaving themselves
completely exposed from the top of the
shield to your throat head that scene
where the horse actually
does fall into the joust list usually
it would be the opposite way so the
person would be getting hit coming off
to the right side based on the fact that
we do real full contact jousting we
always drop the reins so that way there
if you get off balance you're not going
to be pulling your horse to the extent
you're going to be pulling your horse
down onto the ground with you i'm 265
pounds add my armor i'm
415 pounds riding a 2 000 pound horse
charging at 20 25 miles an hour against
the same opposing force it
it's a car wreck so when we hit there is
a lot of force being generated
both guys were not wearing proper
equipment as far as gorgets to protect
their necks because the lance can hit
and come up and straight into your
throat you could tell right away um
looking at the tips of the lances the
hounds lance didn't have a cornell on it
didn't have like a tip on the end it was
a sheer point nights back in the olden
days
the nobility were the ones jousting they
didn't want to go out there and kill
each other and the ends of the lances
had
cornell's put on them again to disperse
the impact force on the knight's armor
it's like a cast fist put on well if you
don't do that you have a scene
possibly like this and
historically that that could have
definitely happened i'm a total game of
thrones geek and i love the show
however i have to give it her four
they you know utilized just that
connection with the horse without the
stirrup the stirrup didn't really come
into play until the battle of hastings
in 1066 a roman
calvary it's
great riders because they're basically
rotting just with that feel and
connection underneath them where the
percherons are now you know 17 18 19
hands tall
they would have never been that tall
they were a lot shorter back then as a
matter of fact they are more
almost the size of a large pony to be
honest with you 14 to 15 hands
his horse was tripped up down the horse
went and down down hugo how does it feel
to
to come off of your horse
well flying through the air is pretty
easy it's the sudden stop when you hit
the ground that really sucks just to be
honest with you he rolled uh so he was
fine it's a muddy muddy terrain um
there's been times when i've you know
come off my horse that i've landed on my
feet next to the horse holding on to the
reins stay on your horse but if your
horse is going to go down
it's best for you to get clear of your
horse because you don't want that
1 500 to 2 000 pound horse
body slamming on top of you my jousting
career i have very little injuries from
my full contact jostling career the more
injuries i've had are training horses
for the sport of jostein and you're
getting on a horse in a
an outfit from battlestar galactica
cylon you know i mean like that's going
to freak a horse out i'd give the whole
scene a definite eight
[Music]
so you have
two different styles of jousting you
have heath ledger um you know with a
targ shield and you have
his competitor coming down and in full
plate harness uh more of a a you know
northern italian style where he had no
shield
[Music]
where
they were saying get it in the cradle
get in the cradle before the cradle was
the uret and on the ends of the lances
they'd have a small disc of wood or um
a ring set in place to be able to catch
this eret so when you bring that lance
down the lance will slide in and lock
into that auret so it'll stop the lance
from going any farther back so all that
pressure comes on to your body and
you're able to give that much more of a
forceful hit
with your body to be able to break those
lances and ultimately unforce your
opponents try and hold on to 1 800
pounds of force i
i hate to admit this but i broke my hand
seven times
trying to learn
how to give devastating hits but i don't
know how many times that a bone has been
sticking through my thumb
in an actual jousting competition even
in this movie you see these horses
completely decked out but it's deceiving
some a lot of people think well they're
wearing that armor to protect the horse
well the horse was never a target as a
matter of fact back in that period of
time if you struck your opponent's horse
you'd be stripped of land and title
why'd they have armor well it was more
of a a car show they didn't want to
bring their volkswagen they brought
their ferrari hey check me out and
that's that's what that horse armor was
for
[Music]
remove your helmet i'm afraid the final
blow of the lance has bent it onto my
head where it's smashed in his helmet um
and he can't get it off
still it happened back then and still
happens today's modern time as well one
of my dear friends took a shot
in the helmet and spun his entire helmet
around breaking his nose
so it looked like it it looked like
literally it
spun his head like a top of course we're
having problems getting it off because
his whole face was all smushed up in
there even if the target's down here you
know often you do get hit in the head of
course heath ledger's helmet no person
in their right mind would have worn that
helmet you do not want the lance to get
in towards your face this helmet uh
you'll see a lot of different designs
this is called a sparrow's beak helm
it's there because when you receive a
direct lance hit
you don't want a flat surface like heath
ledger received and then that hit where
it caved his helmet in it's very very
difficult to cave this style of helmet
in and that's why i use it for my for my
jousting career full contact
is
probably one of the stupidest thing
a man could ever do i give it a seven
and a half
[Music]
the goblins open up the door and they
charge down
that's
a true
maneuver that can easily happen and them
knocking down because they caught them
at surprise and you you'd take 10 guys
and put them behind each other
and take speed a horse that two thousand
pounds or one thousand five hundred
pounds for a lighter horse charging into
that
it's a bowling ball knocking down
bowling ball pins so the question is can
you keep up that inertia and keep on
going so the the initial knock down will
knock the wind out you might not kill
you but it's
the other fifty hundred
thousand two thousand three thousand
horses trampling over top of you just
like cutting grass on a sunday afternoon
you're going to mow down what's in front
of you so
very true and could easily happen and
it did happen you know historically
absolutely do you see king theoden uh
you know kind of wobbling off balance a
little bit it could be the fact that the
actor wasn't comfortable in the saddle
picking up a weapon and wielding it on
horseback again is is that much more
attention to the weapon and less
attention on what you're actually riding
when i train people how to joust i
always tell them
from the hips down rides the horse from
the hips up
does the task so the upper body can stay
you know glued and have a good platform
to be able to wield that sword or couch
that lance or you know spear that ring
or whatever your job entails on that
given specific day
[Music]
all the goblins this time prepped and
prepared with the long
pole arms you know locked down and
locked in place
truly historical defense against the
heavy horse charge
to the extent that
they actually stopped a lot of the
knights would stop doing that heavy
horse charge because that horse was
worth so much to them if they actually
had to fight sometimes they dismount and
run in and fight on foot and not take
their horse you can train a horse all
your life to do this one specific job
and all of a sudden it's it's go time
and the horse realizes it's really
stupid and he'd rather you just go and
fight yourself and he was going to go
back and hang out with the sumpter uh
they had a lot of good historical
elements in there and a lot of good
action that could have been seen on a
battlefield so i actually give it as a
seven
[Music]
so in this situation a loud bang would
just make the horse
run faster it's not gonna know where
that's coming from it would shy more of
the motorcycles coming up beside it than
it would anything else it would not want
to be near the motorcycles but again
in that scenario where you have cars on
left and right the only way it really
can go is forward so the horse is
steering himself at that point if you
have a super fast thoroughbred you're
talking down a street like this easily
35 miles an hour
[Music]
great scene
it looks like keanu reeves did all of
his own stunt there you have to be in
great a great rider to be able to do
that and he pulled it off you know you
could tell he had a stunt saddle on that
had a really high pommel uh that he was
able to grab when he put his foot in the
stirrup to go to the side of the horse
to be able to you know shoot from
the front barrel of the chest in real
life you wouldn't have a pommel that
high you know in front of you to be able
to grab you would find that for stunt
riders not to say that a a good
equestrian can't just on a western
saddle be able to be able to do that it
was a really good stunt very realistic
and could could easily happen
i'd probably give it an eight
this whole scene is absolutely fantastic
back then they didn't have a green
screen or just cgi they knocked it out
of the park
that is 100 percent what
i believe historically a chariot race
would have been like a lot of people
died in the in the chariot races it was
a very dangerous thing i drive a chariot
um
the more horses you add the more power
and more dangerous it gets the chariots
back in that time were were pulled by
one two three
four horses of course you see all these
you know cars doing drifting on tracks
well you know that's nothing because we
can do drifting with a horse and a
chariot it's amazing
those horses are connected by reins
from from the lead horses all the way
back to the driver sitting in the
chariot in the rider's hands
in this point he would have a set for
the left the left horses and the set for
the right horses being able to control
that some riders would have
every horse
reigns coming into his hands and there
is so much power and force that those
drivers to get those
chariots to stop because there really
was no breaks would often have to put
their feet up on the front of the
chariot to be able to pull back with all
their might to be able to get those
horses uh to slow down in front of them
and no cgi no green screen that is
definitely a 10 for a chariot race in my
book
if you have a good riding ability and a
good horse
you can do
anything
on top of that horst how the rider steps
off and a flying y or you know it
switches around for a dub because he
comes back up around the other way and
sits back up on that horse once you form
that partnership with the horse again
you can do
anything with that horse
cool i wish i was that good a lot of
trick riding there the the bow that they
have is is a mounted archery bow um they
use thumb release which is again another
you know
tactic for mounted archery so
historically
a mongolian archer is not somebody you
want to meet in the back alley
absolutely not so yes it is difficult
but you have to realize that they've
been rotting
since birth i think it's a great scene
but i'm not gonna say it can't be done
absolutely it can i'd give it a nine
[Applause]
the style that they're doing is is
open field uh meaning that there's no
actual list they stopped having open
field joust because
the horses were colliding into one
another and they didn't again want those
injuries happening to the horses uh
these were definitely war horses uh to
have two horses charging at one another
is something a normal horse just does
not do you know they are flight flea and
flight animals they are not turn and
charge down animals unless it's a mayor
chasing off a stallion or another
stallion
fighting for for turf with another
stallion
the lances
they could have done a better job the
lances you could tell have a tip on them
so they're a tournament lance it's it's
a cost-saving factor um
and they put new tips on an actual joust
of war which would have been a solid
shaft and would have had the pointed
cornells like not the blunted cornell
like or the flared cornell they would
have had like points on them i'm not
sure
who was teaching them how to jost but
punching with your lance like that
not good you want to hold that lance as
tight as you can to your body because
that's what's going to give that
strength you're not going to get
anything by throwing a punch except for
a broken wrist or a broken hand
[Music]
so when he ducked down the lance also
tipped down and unfortunately killed
that horse this is the chest piece
for a horse the patrol is what it's
called now again it would you know there
to protect the front of the horse's
chest it still gives enough room for the
horse to move its legs underneath but
behind this plate you know ultimately is
the horse's heart and that's where the
heart is and
one of the vulnerable spots
in warfare
to strike to strike a horse
and that's why they protected it
immensely with these plates
this is a grief um
and the the thigh piece is a quees back
in that time the french had the best
armor so it kind of carried through in
today's modern day translation as well
this piece right here
this is you know would go on my
left side my bottom leg but you notice
there's nothing on the inside
well there's nothing on the inside of my
calf because that's how i control and
feel my horse and the reason this is
open is so my calf the inside of my leg
can feel the barrel on my horse and be
able to give cues whether it be left
right forward or back man if they could
have not punched with the lances and
had a solid wooden lance it would have
been a definite 10 but
i'm going to have to give it a 9.
if you enjoyed this video click the link
above for another